ces nouvelles frappes qui ont touché la
centrale nucléaire de zapolijah en
Ukraine une centrale aux mains des
Russes théâtre de nombreux combats ces
derniers jours
ukrainien et russes s'accuse
mutuellement d'être à l'origine de ses
tirs la situation asapolijah a fait
l'objet d'une réunion d'urgence du
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU ce jeudi
les précisions de notre correspondante à
New York Fanny Chauvin
l'enjeu de cette réunion du Conseil de
sécurité c'était bien
d'étudier la demande d'envoi
d'inspecteur de l'IE l'Agence
internationale d'énergie atomique de se
rendre sur place sur dans la plus grande
centrale nucléaire d'Europe et sont
directeur le directeur de a été présent
à la réunion il a rappelé que leur était
grave et que même s'il n'y a pas de
menace immédiate et bien la situation
peut changer à tout moment le directeur
de Yaya que demander aux deux parties
qui Ève et Moscou de coopérer et surtout
d'apporter d'apporter les garanties
nécessaires de sécurité pour le
personnel sur place l'ambassadeur russe
s'est dit prêt à organiser la venue de
ces inspecteurs avant la fin août mais
que cela dépendait de Kiev car Moscou
rejette toujours la responsabilité des
frappes autour de la centrale les deux
pays qui s'accusent mutuellement des
attaques de ces derniers jours l'Ukraine
a donc appelé à créer une zone des
militariser autour de la centrale une
proposition soutenue par les États-Unis
quant à la France lors de cette réunion
et aussi une proposition soutenue par la
nordvège les deux pays un demande à la
Russie de rendre le plein contrôle de
toutes les installations nucléaires
dukraine et le retrait de tout matériel
militaire de ses centrales
l'ancien